foreign
[Music]
escalates the mayor could declare a
state of emergency Council will set up
an Emergency Operations Center where key
staff civil defense and Emergency
Services will work together and share
information and strategies the best way
to stay up to date in your area is to
check council's Facebook page and
website
WE Post regular updates with the latest
information from inside the Emergency
Operations Center evacuations may be
ordered for residents or properties in
areas where a river is about to breach
its banks
Souls affected will be contacted and if
possible emergency response staff will
assist them to evacuate
we ask people to stay with friends or
family outside of the affected area in
the first instance
if that's not possible temporary
accommodation will be provided
when the situation improves civil
defense will issue an all clear message
for people to return home and if
possible emergency response staff can
assist them to do that
foreign